can I just
um don't I don't know what to do
um
um I think
I don't know what to say I'm sorry
you don't know sometimes what to say and
you're basically walking on eggshells
sometimes it can shock people someone
says you're having a good day they just
expect you to say yes out I'm okay and
I'll say no I'm not and some people can
get taken about oh oh and I think
there's the fear of saying the wrong
thing you know what do I know about
Mental Health
I was diagnosed with anorexia nervosa
body dysmorphic disorder and
obsessive-compulsive disorder back in
2013 and on Friday the 29th of August
2014 I tried to take my own life my name
is fakira and I'm sandeep's mom mother
is it best friend my best friend
their first
tournament session
um when he was struggling with his uh
with his mental health and uh from there
we're kind of in a strange way to hit it
off I think it's love at first sight I
like to think
I'm Dr Wilner Cuts I'm a mental health
nurse and Senior lecturer with the open
University
foreign
[Music]
is at the top of the list I think that's
the first and most important step if you
can active listening repeating back some
of the things that they've said to you
sir that they can feel and realize that
they're being helped that first initial
conversation that you had with me when
my mum and dad sat me down that's when
the bubble popped for me that's when I
thought at that very moment that
someone's noticing how I'm feeling
someone is noticing and having an
oversight of my pain just asking how you
are it was so crucial and so important
to me at that moment that's twice you
know are you okay yeah I'm all right but
no you're really okay and then it's like
well no actually I'm not I think there
is an urge to try and problem solve and
do something
and there's almost need sometimes to be
able to fix
a problem or a person and sometimes
that's not the right thing to do in that
situation people aren't necessarily
looking for answers people want to be
heard
one of the things I've learned
as a mental professional is that often
if I try and set goals or have my own
needs and wants and desires for how
somebody should get better
they are usually wrong
and so from my point of view is is
working with a person
at their pace and trying to understand
how they want to move you can suggest go
to your GP you can suggest support
groups you can suggest people taking
that activity you can go and join in
that activity with them so it's they're
not feeling alone with that one size
does not fit all you've had a really
great idea didn't you the Family Trust
yeah cool so what we do we go at the
family environment and go to a coffee
shop or or just sit there all four of us
actually doing our pause and next what's
been your positive for the whole month
what's been your negative for the whole
month we spend a lot of time insulting
each other
[Laughter]
um
each other little videos or oh yeah I've
been watching that and just little Clips
everybody's at the click of a button now
you're in my pocket yeah
if they're really struggling and at
Breaking Point emerges emergency
um phone lines out there and Samaritans
as well they need to know that there is
someone there is support out there and
it's so hard so hard to see that when
you are in a dark place when you're in a
dark place yeah one of the scary things
is that kind of pressure of what what do
I do if because it could be nothing more
scary than having somebody talk to you
about
ending their life
harming themselves in some way really
the person needs to know as well at what
points you'll find something acceptable
or unacceptable
and then have to do something or
involves somebody else I always try and
get that conversation done as soon as I
can to say
look you know I will never breach your
confidence but
if there are things that worry me then
then
I may have to do something about that
and again that's absolutely okay
because a person will thank you for it
afterwards let people know that I'm here
and we're going to do this together so
if that means right if me and you we're
going to make an appointment at the GP
we'll go together and we'll do this
together and it's that about it's about
being in the mud together
you have to keep your own emotional
batteries charged up
because when then drained out you can't
help anybody else and you struggle to
function
let alone just trying to look after
yourself the plane and the oxygen mask
put your oxygen mask on first uh
self-care is is the number one priority
I think
so I don't think you can actually fail
and that's something that I would really
push to everyone who's helping someone
with mental health struggles is you
haven't failed you cannot fail
but you can do something trust again
trust your instincts be yourself the
right thing is probably what you first
felt and that could have been sitting
and listening just nodding or it could
have been responding tell me more about
that
so not too over worry not to overthink
but there is support out there and there
are people that will listen to you and
give you advice and guidance and it's
important to talk oh my God it's so
important to talk very important to talk
we we had motor chats with love you man
you know it's yeah it's good to it's
good to have someone like Josh in my
life it makes my life better
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video